we drop black cards right no black cards
are the premise cards we draw 7-7 whoa
there's so many cars in this thing leave
leave them alone
whoa you have like a hand the hell oh
they also pop up at the bottom of the
screen okay those are the same cab how
do you dress group them all together
like make them like one pile grouped
like you drag a box around them and then
drag them to like the bottom of your
screen and I'll go into like your hand
box okay so how do I see what they say
wait so you can't see this you can't see
this no they just say cards against
humanity' to me
they're blank on that when you flip them
over they're blank oh how this works
that's it you've done it you have you
have one in your hand put them all
wherever you put that one I'm telling
you why don't you have so many cards I
don't know
wait this is really not that complicated
this isn't my fault it seems like your
fault man I know it seems that way to
the untrained eye but over you trial yes
there's a hand on the table and it's a
wait it's a computer wave do you know
what the mouse does you know how we do
yes - who's doing the thing for us I
don't know man I don't know do you want
to play with Rando card rezian who's
that is that next term Rando man
basically we play our cards and then you
put one from the top of the deck in
there's only three of us so why not and
if you if you pick that one then we
should be ashamed of ourselves solving
problems here all right no that's not
where I thought I was putting that no go
back together he thought [ __ ] me you're
doing great
in a field Oh uh-huh
put that on there nope go on the whole
thing there you go and then you just wow
that a mistake was made in this very
obvious system wait you can't I should
have the right to berate him because I
haven't done anything stupid yet oh yeah
you have you did something right we've
got no Rando card rezian and who wait
you get to go first because it's simpler
to be by erase your card dumb-dumb
well I drew for you thank you
blank will never be the same after blank
put your first card on first so when
Wade picks them up and flips them over
the first thing he sees is the first
card he should read right yeah so you
want the first one on the bottom then is
what you're saying yeah so that split
the whole thing yeah when you when you
pick up the pile and and flip it over
the first thing you should see should be
the first one you read if you put your
first card facedown
okay okay we're putting a lot of trust
in Wade's ability to do this this I do
I'm not terrible at things Wow that is
not always true did you guys mix up
whose piles tissues I don't know man
close your eyes or something all good
mm-hmm go for it
I'm gonna start here cuz this is bottom
left and you read left to right
uppercuts will never be the same after
what the [ __ ] did we're the waves if you
just put it into your hand up rakaats
will never be the same after the
Hamburglar god um alright good good play
guys could play collecting all seven
power crystals will never be the same
after taking 2d six emotional damage all
right I might have done wrong what'd you
do wrong bud
stepping on a goddamn friggin Lego will
never be the same after a grumpy old
Harrison Ford rather be doing anything
up you said put it on top the first one
in this way you said the first one put
the first one down on the table first in
the order you intended here the
hamburgers would never be senator
uppercuts probably what that meant to be
and a grumpy old Harrison Ford who'd
rather be doing anything else will never
be the same after stepping on a goddamn
friggin Lego and collecting all seven
power crystals everybody incentive
taking 26 emotional damage or is that
all good everybody happy with the way
that was were read yes yes hmm
choice is clear taking uppercuts that
makes a lot more sense now thank you yes
thank you
mine were seemed mine was yours were
theme I mean they were done it was a
Dungeons & Dragons joke discard that's
discarded [ __ ] that guy maybe we should
put that not where Wade can touch it I
think everything like a professional
thank you very much clock clock clock
wise some marks up yeah mark should read
the card now all right
oh god the pic Tuesday my mom freaked
out when she looked at my browser
history and found blank calm slash blank
I'm gonna close my eyes so I'm picking
up the whole stack and I'm flipping it
yeah so yeah put the one you want read
first on the table first okay put the
second card behind that one so when you
flip it over mark the first thing you'll
see when you flip the whole stack is the
first card you should read right got it
I understand you I see you
so mark look away or whatever like I've
had my eyes closed this entire time no
way do you just shuffle beers I think I
also shuffled mine yeah I did
there you go that and let me do endo
Rando douchebag I have no confidence in
anything that's happening right now all
right there you go yeah okay
all right get him tiger you don't even
have to pick it up if you just mouse
over and press F it'll flip on the table
oh you're so smart my mom freaked out
when she looked on my Brown industry and
found con-com slash demons and [ __ ] all
right fair fair all right my mom freaked
out what you looked at my brother
history and found overcompensation
dot-com slash jumping out at people okay
interesting website I might actually
even visit that don't ya pretty sure my
mom freaked out when she looked at my
browser history and found all the good
cut wait Bob move your hand all the good
times and premium gaming entertainment
available to you in the Kickstarter room
okay dot-com slash lagging out so sad
I'm gonna go with the overcompensation
calm oh no you know what it's my turn to
read the card so that's fine it sure is
we lost two Rando douchebag another pic
- you haven't truly lived until you've
experienced blank and the blank at the
same time I read that wrong but you
don't you what what what why are they
all pick Tuesday hate pick twos get
shuffle the up I'm they're doing that
thing now just draw on the deck shuffle
shuffle here the other side shuffle make
make a shuffle here
go circle here circle back really go
through here yeah and then shuffle shop
got it hundred percent success pick some
cards pick some cards
I guess I'll draw two cards for endo
Calrissian yeah probably I know it's not
or maybe it is but it sounds like when
you say Rando Calrissian that you're
just being like really racist all right
no Calrissian I see but I did not
understand that yeah I guess like I can
see where you're coming on here that now
and I probably would be able to now are
there new Kmart uh it's just cards on
table man come on dude it's not how do
you pick up the whole deck easily it
hold it
I know that alright whatever it also
draw you can also select it might be in
the wrong order
I don't know we're done you know yeah oh
god where's the tape oh it's over here
I was just for a while okay a guy went
way further away from the table that I
meant to okay you haven't truly lived
until you've experienced the imagination
of Peter Jackson and the Star Wars
universe at the same time cinematic nice
I'm truly lived until you've experienced
home video of Oprah's topic into a Lean
Cuisine and getting hilariously gangbang
by the blue man you've experienced Xena
Warrior Princess and go [ __ ] yourself at
the same time I have a feeling that a
Rando who's gonna win again
was that random is that random that
wasn't mine as random holy [ __ ] what is
this hey excuse me what huh what are you
talking about what what is this yeah
yeah wow man someone has strong opinions
oh wow okay
all right checks out checks out you're
right shucks aren't ya yes how good you
are at writing I guess yeah it does
really hurt my feelings this is so well
done here I'll fix it wait I'll fix it
all right draw your thing let's do this
on funny douche bags and this game is
never gonna end how many of these how
long does this go on
35 till you get to seven black cards I
don't know
till we decide that we're done basically
oh here we go well before I killed you
Mr Bond I must show you
blank only one this time which is kind
of nice
so you guys can put them all in one pile
that could shuffle on this time yeah
Rando is two four three one that's
actually one one is what mark to mark or
Bob mark I won yeah I'm the best right
up I mean I'm tied for second for Rando
but didn't someone didn't someone win oh
yeah you didn't yeah a second hey hey
time for third bronze medal all right
before I kill you mr. Martin oh I must
show you whatever Final Fantasy [ __ ]
happened to this year no no before I
kill you mr. Bob never show you my balls
and do a Sega Genesis and pressing the
power button
toldja console before I kill you mr. Bob
and I must show you smashing all the
pottery in a pottery barn in search of
rupees big Zelda Finn it's gotta be
balls
thank you thank you I'm the best I am
great I'm the best I am the best I'm
great Bob you see the text me which one
you put so I cannot pick is gotta be
fair man blank there's an app for that
crippling debt there's an app for that
keep cockfights there's an app for that
poor people for that yeah yeah ergo I'm
gonna go with the poor people random
douche bag
I get all these shitty cards and it was
like oh you want people I had poor
people hi this is Jim from accounting we
noticed that a $1200 charge to label the
blank can you explain me this [ __ ]
shitty card put this in my stupid hand I
just want to get rid of all of my cards
and draw all over again because these
are all horrible how about we get one
reset per game like full hand reset
early yeah why not
that makes it interesting can we I will
scrap every one of these yes go for it
go for you can use it whenever you want
but go for it all right what was the
card I wasn't paying attention
oh yeah this is Jim from accounting we
noticed a 1200 our charge labeled blank
can you explain hi this is Jeff from
accounting we noticed 12 knowledge level
several Michael Keaton's charge a
labeled being rich 12 dollar charge a
labeled ammo P zoo lion
can you explain I would not look forward
to that email god damn it well it's
gotta be being rich notice me doing
these is there a max to the number of
cards you can have in your hand okay
listen listen oh my god guys if you hit
G on a random stack of cards it does
that oh if you have like cards that are
all like shitty and whatever hit G
for oh this hands already a lot better
than the last oh good yeah I'm glad I'm
glad man I'm glad time for me to have a
black car to not play
I'm glad man after the earthquake Sean
Penn brought blank to the people of
Haiti I always loved whenever I have the
Sean Penn card and you just have Sean
Penn brought Sean Penn funny joke all
right whatever
good good joke but thanks good I was
laughing after the earthquake Sean Penn
brought futuristic death sports the
people of hid dad's fun probably is
futuristic this futuristic I mean
technology right after you have quake
Sean Penn brought literally eating [ __ ]
just people Sean Penn brought you must
construct additional layers to doctor in
the hospital is like give me more like
you must get right I'm the best look at
me turns out that Blankman was neither
the hero we needed nor wanted oh no a
real winner right there shuffle shuffle
shuffle all right let's do this [ __ ]
weights penis that's really distracting
I'm sorry I didn't mean to blip it out
there all right he's shuffled okay here
we go
huh turns out that dead babies boom man
was neither the hero we needed nor
wanted turns out that party poopers man
was out that Rufus oh [ __ ] oh god I
can't even tell it was just a random one
I'm on their grabby boys this is a
toughy I mean those are all great heroes
that no one wants I just become I think
the visual is funnier I'm gonna go with
party pooper man yes I played roofies
man I was a close second thank you very
alright I'm up do it do the do with our
most extreme flavor yet get ready for
mountain to blank
what was it I wasn't paying attention do
the do with our most extreme flavor yet
get ready for Mountain Dew Blanc what is
a snore swartz those are two R's these
getting there literally one white card
in front of me come on now that's mine I
did my job I I'm really debating this
I'm really but really thinking about
this hard I feel like there's some [ __ ]
being written here maybe doesn't belong
it's written in yellow which is the same
color as Marc's name I wonder if there's
a coincidence you can but I feel like
there's a reason it's all in yellow okay
wait hang on do the do with our most
extreme flavor yet get ready for
Mountain Dew feeding Rosie O'Donnell
yeah Mountain Dew the pure zen-like
state that exists between micro and
macro let's get ready for about ndu
going around punching people the only
one that's even close were you going
around punching people no I was not what
is this loves it when you deliver food
ah he absolutely loves the fact that I
eat on stream
so hungry hey hey wait a minute hey hey
come on now I didn't write this what's
happening wait wait no I didn't write
this
what don't don't believe it clearly
clearly written by mark and suddenly
endorsed by Wade
I suck hard but Marco what is what is
this is this heart but yeah yeah I suck
heart but yeah I admit it but hey Wade
shorts grandma's ashes so much like I do
sweat grandma's ashes apparently drive
car no next time on dr. Phil how to talk
to your child about blank make it funny
mine's real funny mine thank you so
funny
the way you guys are selling this as I
don't I don't believe you but mine is
very funny shut up and read it I'm
reading next time I dr. Phil how to talk
to your child about a one-way ticket to
Gary Indiana
oh how to talk to your chat about sharks
with legs spending the years insulin
budget on warhammer
okay figure EADS I think probably would
talk about there's a whole undertone of
disowning your child the joke is so
complex I'm not surprised that way about
yourself
it's not second place so you're better
off than that at least you know whatever
whatever whatever whatever mr. no cards
you had no funny cuz you don't have any
black cards you don't know that I know
that I see that everybody we could see
that pretty clearly one do you want to
do the to pick or do you want to ditch
it could be Feb redraw something to you
I just don't like to furs alright what
do we do I am in the city that never
sleeps the door swings open and she
walks in legs up to here
something in her eyes tells me she's
looking for blank hey guys I learned a
new trick what what is that a few
drawing cards if you draw one and then
hold it and then right-click you can
draw oh wow that's really useful right
that's real handy just what I said
alright here we go 2 a.m. in the city
that never sleeps the door swings open
she walks in legs up to here something
in her eyes tells me she's looking for
the kool-aid man well looking for
historically black colleges no looking
for she was looking for [ __ ] Mountain
look dear Mom and Dad camp is fun I like
capture the flag yesterday and one of
the older kids taught me about blank I
love you
Casey wait your hand shouldn't be in my
hand it should be on your hand what are
you doing what weights weights fingers
wait fingers is over here I was reading
the car away go away what's happened go
dude party over here do your stuff go do
your there you go who's if away fly away
a little boy I'm all gone mo gone hero
dad campus fun I like caps the fly
yesterday one of the older kids taught
me about all my friends dying I love you
Casey
you're my dad cam it's fun I like
capture the flag yesterday one of my
older kids taught me about anchoring I
love you Casey do you pay what if the
older kid know it says fingering one of
the older kids taught me about jerking
off to incense second realmedia clipped
well I have a guess I don't have a guest
for which one of these this Rando
actually
yeah yeah oh yay yay shadow shout-out to
ten-second real media clips downloaded
on LimeWire everybody fingering was the
r and everybody's favorite port and
whatever that was client you guys ever
torrent movies and segments from lime
where no not in segments now I was
asleep or NAND jeff foxworthy clips
that's what I did that is not a lot when
I was my dad really really liked Jeff
Foxworthy and like all those guys like
yeah he I was into it so I had like one
CD that I burned and I took on road
trips I was the porn CD
well we'll always get you laid uh can't
read my cards cuz i got too many black
cards I've got so many black guys I just
put them on the left they go under the
cards so they're not in the way no no
yes yes we all know that was just a
charity pick wait calm down come on it
was good come on
no you man i like this i had [ __ ]
about yeah you didn't win because of
skill you wouldn't because you had like
the trumpet that's all anyone ever was
before no no this game is 100% skill
[ __ ] you what will always get you late
explosions a manger and pants yeah what
will always get you late
being awesome at sex how do you know
that ahead of time do you like said yes
i feel like that presumes a lot I feel
like I'm sorry hard to prove prior to
getting laid what will always get you
laid my sex dungeon agent that one's for
you so what was the big inside joke
agent just say Asian Oh
agent sex dungeons in Asia Asians that
one's for you damn anyway being awesome
at sex you find that out after the fact
your sex dungeon if you're going into it
you already know what you're getting
into but explosions guarantee the
[ __ ] Rando random this game you have
been waylaid by blank and must defend
yourself I'm not sure what waylaid means
but I kind of pick it up from the
context here
don't mix it up with all my winnings
don't write my winnings your there's so
many of them I could see that happening
laid by the fifth the 3/5 compromise and
must defend yourself you have been
waylaid by heartwarming Minges and must
defend yourself that there's three
different ways to look at this oh
there's three cards yeah I see that
about 3/5 mm-hmm heartwarming orphans is
because I imagined this old man with too
much money going like oh sure that's the
RAM okay no I'm just gonna start taking
credit for the randos goddamn cards next
time there's a winner and someone's like
yeah every Christmas my uncle gets drunk
and tells the story about blank
alright I'm gonna also shoot away I'm
also doing a card purge every Christmas
my kid struck it tells the story about
carbon monoxide poisoning every
Christmas my own food gets drunk and
tells the
story about a brain tumor hilarious gets
drunk and tells the story about balls
damn despite how hilarious the brain
tumor is its balls mine it's mine it's
mine guys that's mine thank you it was
my balls I said a or B to chat earlier
when I'd [ __ ] Mountain it was between
balls 87% confident of my balls in my
[ __ ] the video killed the radio star
wave so cry me at goddamn River I like
this new action comedy oh no a nice like
this I can't read and his new action
comedy Jackie Chan must fend off ninjas
while also dealing with we're still here
well someone played a ninjas card like
two hands ago it was my endless ninjas
yeah we could have had ninjas nimblest
ninjas random would have picked it cuz
no one here I did Rand already you're
not in charge of picking anything you
get you and I'll take that card no it's
mine [ __ ] you [ __ ] you to thank [ __ ] you
thank you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you thank you
new action comedy the Jackie Chan was
fending off ninjas while also dealing
with Gandalf Bob your hand is that's
oddly on topic for today while also
dealing with a boxing match with a giant
box you know honestly I would watch this
movie with Gandalf yes I want to watch
that transgression it's an action comedy
therefore the comedy of boxing a giant
box there was the action with the ninjas
but you needed the funny
wait this is why you don't understand
comedy why aren't you gonna listen to
support and watch Jeff Fox for I wake up
America Christmas is under attack by
secular liberals and they're blank there
you go dude do your business okay I'm
ready
wake up America Christmas is under
attack by secular liberals and their
actual mutants with medical conditions
no whose super powers
wake up American Christmas is under
attack by Nicolas Cage
wake up America Christmas is under
attack by secular liberals and they're
waterboarding mutants yes the comeback
is real baby wasted Nicolas Cage on you
yeah you did
yeah you did all right I'm gonna start
playing just Trump cards here for my own
I got great one okay all right then the
healing process began when I joined a
support group for victims of blank take
your time there fellas it's been four
seconds all right the healing process
began when I joined a support group for
victims of Chris Evans grabbing his left
boob laughing victims of pac-man
uncontrollably guzzling [ __ ] and victims
of getting bitch-slapped by dhalsim I
would know who that is
Dhalsim sounds familiar no I don't know
very much about a lot of these I'll just
pick a random alright next no no no I
choose pac-man yes damn what about Chris
Evans grabbing his boob and laughing
made me chuckle it made me chuckle yeah
soft a flaccid chuckle does not around
wind sir oh and you were just goofing at
pac-man where are you see what I did
controllably controllably tickles now
prohibit blank on airplanes here we go
tsa guidelines now prohibit getting so
angry that you pop a boner on airplanes
they do not like people that are angry
and they probably don't like boners tsa
guidelines now prohibit amputees on
airplanes well that's United tsa
guidelines now prohibit a bleached
[ __ ] on airplanes they're already
checking anyway what does it make a
difference
[Applause]
tee's was so outrageous how could you
not
what have better emotion Scot damn you
all right up next on Nickelodeon
Clarissa explains Blanc got it 10 on its
head just get mine everyone else sucks
all right fair enough
you go home Andrew your sad existence
you write you write up next Nickelodeon
closer Clarissa
Clarissa explains dead parents Clarissa
explains white privilege Larissa
explains shaft shaft damn oh yeah no no
no randoms you're just [ __ ] snow back
and watch this belongs to not you if you
weren't stuffing your face hole with a
junior bacon cheeseburger what am I
giving up for Lent what about giving up
for Lent mooing mmm scrotal frostbite
good stuff good stuff good stuff or a
super soaker full of cat pee well I
can't give that up I mean I feel like
it's supposed to be something that
you're giving up that you really
appreciate so mooing yay we're all
pretty bad there's no way that was
really you multi stream works card don't
buy hey whoa hey whoa a wise now even my
- hey whoa hey whoa
hey whoa hey whoa I don't know if I
believe you but that's fine I don't know
I doc that was my card I was like this
Carol frostbite was definitely your call
was that your card no I was all the way
I don't even know how this game works
anymore
I shall EB no I shall erect a 50-foot
statue to commemorate bling I shall also
be erect if I'm a billionaire
what's the statue gonna be this is a
markiplier card throw now what do you
mean there's no custom cards okay I'm
just throwing it out there when I have a
billionaire I slowly write the 50 foot
statue to commemorate crying into the
pages of Sylvia Plath it's not a poet
writer yeah yeah okay one billionaire
how shall I write put statue to
commemorate pooping back and forth
forever okay the great Aaron Hanson
that's what he likes to do all right he
likes to poop a lot that's why whatever
like a poop I think of Karen is such a
good thing a bad thing
yeah okay I shall wreak 50-foot statue
to commemorate John Wilkes Booth man oh
man what a shot that guy has too soon
you said yes thank you
just like this is like dude one dude two
or art not dude making an infinite poop
loop could be a cubbyhole old boy or
girl
come come right up in here and just just
stand up here no we're ready to receive
the poops and there could be a parent
standing over here and some force
perspective booth was like right not
that camera that was Lincoln yes it was
like it okay what's the shot Kennedy
John Wilkes Booth no stop
he's got three names that's the only
thing I know Lee Harvey Oswald oc3 names
now I was right I was right booth was
Lincoln you right right mark I'm good
why do you have one card [ __ ] over in
your hand whatever whatever I don't what
are you talking about don't look at my
hand
stop looking at my hand so all I see is
blank other than what I see one card
says what's going on again doesn't
matter it doesn't matter do whatever you
want
oh it says uh both sides oh wow he's
cheating he's got a double-sided card oh
[ __ ] looks [ __ ] cheating over no that
was the wrong side to art blank awesome
in theory kind of a mess in practice
here we go double penetration awesome in
theory kind of a mess in practice that
makes a right you right you right right
coughing into practice you a nuanced
critique want some Theory kind of a mess
in practice I'm gonna go with double
penetration yeah damn it you meant
coughing into a vagina was wait was that
theory
it's notice now in one who's Theory
who's married and who's not sorry life's
pretty tough in the fast lane
that's why I never leave the house would
be blank why do you put your hand
directly over it I'm reading it I just
want to see my hand is small on my
screen so it doesn't make sense to me
that it affects your reading or whatever
go for it go for it
I was paying attention life's pretty
fast in the toughest lane that's why I
give me a goddamn white card to shut up
I did the random already oh well who was
a giving you one I haven't shut up
so what he's saying is you have all the
information in that scenario to figure
that for you statement in hopes of
provoking further ridicule and marks
direction what you mean is you meant to
be making it in a rhetorical statement
in order to jab at Marco interrogative
statement Co that you could have found
yourself you right you right
Jack you right you right you right you
right
alright life's pretty faster than
whatever I never leave the house without
some really fucked-up [ __ ]
I was definitely weeds I never leave the
house without [ __ ] and I never leave
the house without an honest cop with
nothing left to lose that takes care of
life in the fast lane I guess it was
mine everyone here socks that is not
funny
loving you is easy because you're blank
I have no card that actually makes you
know Bob I wasn't gonna do this but
you've made me feel like this is your
fault
Freddie sure there now points to you
there it's been four seconds thirteen
times I put random in there thank you
loving you is easy cuz your socks
what good lovin news easy because you're
poor life choice it's [ __ ] soft I
literally it was the only card in my
hand that was like actually a noun
everything else weirds like grandiose
[Laughter]
mark wins if we're if we're keeping
score because I think its first a seven
points yeah I got seven we can do one
more if you want sure you guys got a
card you're burning to deal with like
now is that sure all right
why am i sticky all right do it why am i
sticky God sticky half-assed foreplay
huh yeah why am i sticky rock music and
premarital sex I mean that makes sense
that makes sense that makes sense
they all make sense I see the common
denominator here is probably that middle
card weird
I think this card right here is the
common denominator as to why these three
are good right yeah yeah yeah I'm right
you're right
I'm gonna go with rock music and
premarital sex oh my god well thought
for sure that one was was Bob so I was a
fast four please
I was god I was about to pick a god I
was doing a previous life I've God - I'm
trying to count how many black cards
yeah yeah yeah - this three so twelve
was it twelve eleven a couple of these
were like do-overs right you right you
right you
[Laughter]
[Music]